there's trustees with us now hi good
morning good morning thanks for joining
us this morning
um let's start with that trade deal
should we um
those who are being critical say it's
more showcase and substance
well i completely disagree with this
this is the first uk trade deal that
we've struck from scratch
since brexit it's not just important in
itself it's got
huge opportunities with australia
whether it's about the under 35s being
able to go there
for three years without any farm work
requirement whether it's about
tariffs reduced on all british goods
from whiskey to cars
but what's more it's also about access
to the wider pacific market
so we want to sign up to the
trans-pacific partnership
a market of 11 countries 500 million
people
and doing this australia deal is a key
part of that as well and of course
that's where the growing demand is sure
but that's
all the kind of products and services
that we that's why people are saying
that's why it's a showcase because
actually was percent of increase in gdp
about 1.20 per household per year well
that's a static analysis but what that
analysis doesn't take into account
is that those economies are growing and
they're growing fast
so we're expecting trade with australia
to increase by 30 percent
by 2030 and with a wider trans-pacific
area
we're expecting it to increase by 65 so
what i'm doing
is striking these trade deals that are
going to put the uk in a very strong
position
you know in 2030 and 2040 and 2050
because our businesses whether it's
financial services or
technology or farmers
or whiskey they will have a bigger
market to sell into
and the british will have better access
than other countries so this deal for
example with australia
we have now got more access for brits to
go and live and work
in australia than the americans have all
the japanese have so we've got a real
strategic advantage
okay at the expense of our farmers some
might say um a huge increase in meat
imports into the united kingdom 25 times
what it is at the moment is what the cap
is likely to be
emily thornbury the shadow trade
secretary as you know saying
send our farmers to the wall and the
national farmers union representative
chairman in fact uh minet batters saying
uh we're really gonna have to look at
this very carefully it's just not good
for our farmers
well what we are doing is we're making
sure there's a transition period for
farmers of 15 years
so we're going to give australia the
same access
that the eu have to our market in 15
years time
the eu already has quota free access
to the uk so they already sell us 230
000
tonnes of beef per year what this deal
is talking about
is next year it will be 35 000 tons so
we
we import far more beef from the eu
than we do from australia and what we're
talking about is rectifying that in 15
years time
it's on a sliding scale though of course
isn't it it's on its guiding scale but
none of
none of the amounts on that sliding
scale are as big
as the amount we import from the eu okay
and first of all
australia mainly sell into the asia
pacific market
which has much higher prices than here
in the uk and europe
but what the deal will also enable us to
do is get more opportunities for our
farmers
in those markets like vietnam like those
other markets
where there is growing demand for
british beef and lamb
so we need to look outwards i think
we've got to stop being defensive
and look at where the opportunities are
okay how will this trade deal complicate
matters
in northern ireland um given that
currently the government doesn't want to
enforce
any checks as far as northern ireland is
concerned the eu
is reducing checks on australia goods
the eu is going to be looking at this
and saying
hang on a minute well this trade deal is
fully compatible with a northern ireland
protocol
but what the issue is in northern
ireland
is we need the eu to be compa pragmatic
about the checks that are undertaken and
that was always the way the protocol was
drafted
it requires compromise between the
parties
and the eu need to be reasonable and
that's what lord frost is asking for
deal's a deal though isn't it well the
deal was clear
within the terms of the northern ireland
protocol that there had to be
a pragmatic approach and that's what we
need to see
from the eu so we might go past the 30th
of june with our negotiations in order
to try to get this deal
over the line it's already over the line
but sorted well lord frost continues to
be in discussions with the eu to sort
this situation
out but i would urge the eu to be
responsible and be pragmatic
to sort this issue out um let me talk
about vaccines if i may
mandatory vaccination for care home
staff is that the case
well we are currently consulting on this
issue
but what we do know is that it's
incredibly important
that staffing care homes are vaccinated
we've got a hugely vulnerable population
in our care homes and making sure
that staff are vaccinated is a priority
and everybody
who has the opportunity for a vaccine
should take up that opportunity because
it's helped proven protect all of us
and keep all of us safe okay exactly
they don't have one
two i i i'm not gonna comment because we
haven't
we haven't got the well we haven't
responded to the consultation be
responsibly wrong
of me to prejudge that consultation but
it's clearly
if you had a parent who was in a care
home i would want to make sure i would
want the staff to be vaccinated
of course i would because i would want
my parent to be protected
what about nhs staff well i think
everybody who has the opportunity to
have a vaccine
should have that vaccine and that's what
we want to make sure is that all
adults are vaccinated and what jeopardy
should there be if you don't have that
vaccination
well these are all issues that we're
looking at as part of the consultation
we will
respond to that consultation i can't
prejudge that but you do think but i'm
very much of the view
that we need to protect everybody in
society and the vaccine is a way to do
that and we've seen the huge progress
we've been able to make
as a result of our very strong record in
vaccination
just reading um jacob reese mogg this
morning i'm sure you've been reading
what he's had to say as well it was
actually on his podcast or modcast i
think he calls it very clever
um and it's been picked up by a lot of
the newspapers this morning
saying that we can't run a society to
stop hospitals uh
becoming full isn't that exactly what we
are doing at the moment
what we're doing is we are taking a
pragmatic approach
the key is making sure that everybody
gets vaccinated
uh by the 19th of july we'll have all
over 40s vaccinated so that we are
protected
as a society that's what we need to do
in order to be able to
fully open up the economy but what do we
think about what jacob reese morgan said
i mean he's completely gone off the
reservation
well i haven't actually read his uh read
his blog
read his blog this morning but let me
tell you he says
um lockdown cannot drag on just to
prevent people seeing a doctor
and that we can't run a society to stop
hospitals being
uh being full well i agree with him that
lockdown
shouldn't drag on we want to bring an
end to it we've already
taken a number of steps to open up uh
parts of the economy
uh things are freer than they were a few
months ago
but i think we need to hold our nerve uh
to make sure
that we keep levels of the virus down
and the way to do that is through
vaccination yeah but does he not
understand that
he literally the government's policy is
uh to have locked down or easing of
lockdown but still
restrictions in place at the moment in
order to stop our hospitals being
fulfilled i mean it's fundamentally
the point isn't it well the whole point
is fundamentally to protect people
and to stop people uh suffering severe
coverage and dying and that is why we're
doing this we're protecting lives
that is the ultimate aim do you accept
that he's misspoken then
well i i don't know i come you just you
just read it out to me and uh
papers it's no secret well jacob
jacob jacob has his you know his views
and that's
those are his views but what i'm telling
you is the what the reason we are doing
this the reason we are taking these
measures
is to protect lives and that's what's
important i suppose the more serious
point is that it's
the discontent with with an extension to
lockdown
um is now reaching the front bench he's
the lead of the house
when you go out and about in the uk
and talk to people about their
experiences on lockdown what they want
to see
there is huge support for the prime
minister's approach
of being cautious of making sure that we
do have people vaccinated
before we fully open up the economy we
don't want to be in a position
where we have to go backwards because
we've seen a spike
and that is why the vaccination program
is so vitally important and
there's huge public support for that
have you had both your jobs
i haven't i've got i've got one due on
saturday okay so i will be
i will be double backed then yeah did
you have oxford i did
yes no actually not at all i had to do i
had to do a media around the next
morning so i couldn't
i couldn't be poorly two days i was so
poorly but having said that
i'm 100 invincible now i've had both
jobs and yours is this weekend
it is good thank you very much thanks a
lot